this film is primarily a fun clever
emotional story of family income and
wasp also connects directly to Avengers
for these characters are going to be
very important going forward well you
heard it from the man himself Kevin
Feige president of Marvel Studios says
that ant-man and the wasp connect
directly with Avengers 4 but also note
that he says these characters are going
to be very important going forward so
it's not just the movie it's not just
the quantum realm it's not just ant-man
it's the character so we're gonna talk
about what this means and how this all
connects directly with Avengers 4 before
we get started spoiler alert there are
major spoilers for ant-man and the wasp
both the movie and the post-credits
scene so if you don't want any spoilers
for the movie turn back now also don't
forget to subscribe to my channel so you
can stay up to date on ant-man and the
wasp and everything related to Avengers
4 so if you saw the movie you know that
really the connection to Avengers 4
takes place in the post-credits scene in
the post-credits scene of ant-man and
the wasp it shows Scott Lang hope Janet
and dr. Pym on the top of the building
on the top of the building they have a
miniature version of the quantum tunnel
that we saw during the movie set up in
the back of Louis's van Scott Lang or
the ant-man is about to go back into the
quantum realm but before he does Janet
Van Dyne has some words of caution for
him first she says make sure you stay
out of the tardigrade fields they're
cute but they'll eat you but then she
says and don't get sucked into a time
vortex we won't be able to save you this
line right here is the key to Avengers 4
we know that Avengers 4 is going to be a
time travel movie so it appears that in
this scene they're telling us just how
they'll time-travel then as ant-man goes
into the quantum realm and is ready to
return we find out that hope Janet and
dr. Pym have all turned to ash due to
Thanos a snap
so this scene right here just set up
Avengers for Paul Rudd is confirmed to
be in Avengers 4 and is set to have a
substantial part in the movie Evangeline
Lilly is also set to up a partner movie
which is a little odd scene as how she's
dead so I think it's safe to assume that
she'll return when all of the other
characters who are taken out by thanasis
snap return as well because we know it's
gonna happen so back to the time vortex
Scott is totally going in the time
vortex it's kind of his only option to
escape the quantum realm and Marvel made
it this way by making hope Janet and
Hank victims to thanasis snap those
three are the only people that could
bring him out maybe bill foster a ghost
but who knows if they survived and if
they did how the heck would they even
find the van on top of a random roof so
Scott will most likely have no choice
but to go through a time vortex to
escape the quantum realm and since it's
a time vortex he's not gonna end up in
the same time as he left so there's
really only two options the past or the
future and my assumption is that he ends
up in the future this will line up with
the plot the leaked photos and the
theories surrounding Avengers 4 and
time-travel in the leaked set photos
we've seen of Avengers 4 we see an older
Tony Stark a man is obviously right next
to him and Captain America is there as
well but based on the uniform that he's
wearing it looks like this is the
Captain America from the first Avengers
movie so what I'm guessing happens is
that ant-man goes through the time
vortex and goes into the future when he
gets to the future it will obviously be
very different considering half of
humanity will be gone due to Thanos I'm
guessing someone he knows will still be
alive whether that's his daughter Louise
his ex-wife ghost doctor bill foster
some way or another he's going to talk
to somebody and figure out what happened
from there he'll search for Tony Stark
and once he finally meets Tony he'll
explain how he went through a time
vortex via the quantum realm up until
this point Tony and the rest of the
surviving Avengers would probably
already be looking for a way to time
travel or get the Infinity stones from
Thanos and seen as how Thanos is most
likely on a
stored tighten and nowhere to be found
their best option is to time travel
so when Scott Lang appears to Tony it'll
be clear that the way to time travel is
through the quantum realm from there him
and dr. Bruce Banner who is still alive
will figure out a way to access the
quantum realm because although Scott
Lang has been in the quantum realm he is
not a quantum physicist and has no idea
what's going on which is made pretty
clear in ant-man on the wasp
but his key role will be navigating the
quantum realm he's the only person alive
at that time who has been inside the
quantum realm and successfully navigated
through it so Tony and Bruce will figure
out how to access the quantum realm and
then ant-man is going to be the one to
guide them through it and from here
they'll navigate throughout time and
possibly try to collect some Infinity
stones so there it is there is the way
that Ant Man and the wasp connect
directly to Avengers 4 through the time
vortex in the quantum realm and that's
my theory on how some of the events will
take place in Avengers 4 what did you
all think about Ant Man and the wasp and
what do you think is gonna happen when
ant-man goes through that time vortex
hit me with your thoughts in the
comments below and be sure to LIKE this
video and subscribe to my channel so you
can stay up to date on all things
related to Avengers 4 Marvel DC and
superhero thank you so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]